hey leute und willkommen zu einer
snapshot vorstellung soeben es die
minecraft version 12 w 7 30h von cap
veröffentlicht wurden
und mal wieder sind ein paar
interessante sachen dazu gekommen die
ich euch nun mal ganz kurz vorstellen
werde
wir gehen einfach mal auf das
singleplayer menü und wenn wir nun hier
irgendeine welt auswählen zum beispiel
survival games die ich mir runter
geladen habe können wir auf recreation
dann können wir einerseits den namen
ändern nenne ich mal eben zum beispiel
www gamescom
dann können wir den gamer ändern of
survival oder hardcore oder creative und
dann können wir hier beim world options
den zieht verändern und alles mögliche
können wir hier verändern
man kann übrigens auf den tätern
anzeigen lassen kann den kopieren und so
weiter nur ändern würde ich den halt
nicht also man kann quasi die welten re
kreieren und außerdem wenn man nun eine
neue welt erstellt ich mach mal creative
kann man auf my world options klicken
hier auf superflat und da kann man hier
customized klicken dann kann man hier
zum beispiel auf einen block draufgehen
of prey setzen kann man hier so ein paar
andere sachen auswählen zum beispiel
dass dann der wüste ist oder so ganz
oben da hier sieht dann sieht man immer
die höhe wo das angezeigt wird der
unterste flores damit ich bedrock und so
weiter also kann man schon ein paar
einstellungen mehr vornehmen so aber wir
wollen einfach in der welt reingehen und
zwar eine änderung die ich nicht so ganz
verstanden bzw
ich habe es verstanden aber ich war ich
habe es nicht hingekriegt dass das
funktioniert und zwar wenn man auf ein
schwein rechtsweg macht kann man
angeblich wenn man das steuertöpfen aber
ich kann es nicht steuern und ich kann
auch nicht hüpfen und was ich dann geht
mir gedacht habe okay gut vielleicht
geht es dann mit der karotte und steckt
jetzt habe ich ja dass hier und das
läuft ja immer dahin wo die karte zeigt
seht ihr aber trotzdem wenig space druck
gehüpft es nicht und rechts links fällt
macht nix also ich war jetzt nicht ganz
genau was das bringen soll und wie man
das aktiviert wenn ihr wisst bitte
einfach mal in die kommentare schreiben
dann werde ich euch da sehr dankbar also
man kann auf schweinen nun hüpfen wenn
man die leitet nach post so gut gucken
hier es bei der schweiz also es gibt nun
einen pumpkin kuchen
also einen kürbiskuchen dass man nun
endlich am kinn ist kürbis pumpkin ja
ich glaub am kinn des körpers ich mir
selber mag das nicht so gerne aber naja
bis jedem seinen geschmack in minecraft
ist es auf jeden fall ganz gut den kann
man sich einfach so essen aber kann ich
halt grad nicht also nicht ersetzen
sondern wirklich einfach nur so essen
und wie viel der ein leben auf hört er
kann ich euch auch nicht zeigen weil ich
das noch nicht getestet habe aber könnt
ihr selber testen und da steht auch
alles in minecraft forum
dann gibt es eine neue textur und einen
neuen namen und zwar heißen die karotten
und nicht mehr karies sondern carrot
also in der einzahl und die textur von
der karotte und der goldenen kamera
wurde auch geändert dann wird auch die
textur von der kappe dem brustpanzer der
hose und den schuhen geändert das seht
ihr hier
wir haben so ein bisschen mehr vorm
angenommen finde ich sie ganz
interessant aus und ja außerdem bekommt
man beim angeln erfahrungspunkte hatte
ich aber keine lust euch das zurzeit
weil er hätte ich jahrelang welche jahre
lang rum gestanden und tippt versuchten
fisch zu angeln
aber wie kommen zwei nächsten änderungen
und zwar kann man einfach drücken wenn
er im chat dann kann man / klima ein
schrein schreiben dann wurden alle meine
items die ich hatte
remove dich hatte elf items und inventar
ich kann euch das auch mal zeigen wenn
ich mir zum beispiel den stack gras
black hole strecke cleared dann steht
auf 64 teams wurden ruft also das
höchstes dann einfach alles voll wie man
alles vom mit 64 1 teams hat so keine
ahnung 1000 m wurden ruft oder so ist
eigentlich ganz cool wenn dem creative
ist und dann muss man nicht immer hier
und dann jedes einzelnen münzen und das
ist auf jeden fall deutlich besser
dann gab es noch kleine änderungen am
wetter also in diesen bus und zwar
nachdem seine lebensleistung nach dem
spawn gefüllt wurde
er erzeugt er eine explosion um sich
selber herum sage ich mal
knöpfe erzeugen nun auch ein längeres
redstone signal nach der aktivierung und
die textur von allen nahrungsmitteln und
des sterns wurden außerdem geändert die
haben nun eine kleine schwarze umrandung
mehr kann ich euch hier zeigen
angeblich haben die irgendwelche um
andere handlungen das sieht man hier
beim coupé oder beim kuchen zum beispiel
sieht man jetzt nicht all zu doll hier
wenn man das so macht dann erst recht
nicht aber hier unten die umrandung ist
halt neu dazugekommen und was auch ganz
interessantes ist wenn man auf hart
spielt und dann zum beispiel in der
höhle reingeht dann gehen monster ein
höheres risiko ein
ihn zu töten das heißt wie springen auch
teilweise marc lippen runter wenn sie
denn dabei nicht sterben das heißt ich
glaube die sterben bei bauer weiß nicht
ich würde mal tippen 20 blöcke
herunterfallen oder so und dann fünf
blöcke oder so wenn ihr weiter unten
seit auf peaceful wird auf facebook
einiges machen aber auf easy würden sie
dann nicht runter springen aber so
würden die darunter springen und ja das
war es auch eigentlich schon an den
änderungen
ich packe euch mal den zieht
beziehungsweise den cee'd gebe ich mal
so ein ding könnt ihr jetzt irgendwie
ein screenshot von machen
den könnt ihr euch einfach mal selber
eingeben und zwar als portier da hinten
irgendwo hier über fliegt seit ich hier
wirklich einer interessanten
konstruktion also finde ich sehr
interessant die sind sehr hier könnt ihr
einfach mal machen wäre auch geeignet
für jockeys aber einfach nur den habe
ich so aus zufall erwischt das coole
stars auch eine höhle aber das geld
jetzt nicht zum dingens nicht zum
snapshot sondern das ist einfach mal so
der bayer so ist ein ganz interessantes
sieht und dann würde ich mal sagen wenn
ihr 1000 like schafft dann lade ich
nachher noch eine sieht vorstellung
hochschülerschaft und dann würde ich
sagen sie uns beim nächsten mal chelsea